isabella rossellini vous n'avez pas
beaucoup les interviews
sorte de temps en temps j'ai j'espère je
les vis et l'annoncé peu à peu se
parlent toujours de votre père et votre
mère c'est pour sa base oui mais c'est
pas que j'aime pas vraiment père de ma
mère mais des produits frais de pose des
questions et je ne sais pas répondre
alors par hasard par exemple vous
ressemblez à votre mère
me demandent des choses comme comment
est ce que vous sentez à être la fille
du gouverneur alors moi je ne sais plus
quoi répondre parce que j'étais la fille
claude et guy delmas et baptêmes de
comparer ces deux fois c'est difficile
pour cette raison c'est la question
qu'on me pose le plus souvent ça oui que
je me semble même elles ont été laissées
ça me fait de notre pays beaucoup zèle
physique de votre mère et le caractère
de votre père est en vie on dit ça aussi
vous avez fait vous même des interviews
non oui j'ai fait en effet cette
révisées sont très difficiles sont très
difficiles à perdre en interview surtout
aux gens connus parce que des gens tenu
l'enfant constamment ils sont ils ont
l'habitude ils ont l'habitude dix ans il
se sent fatigué il n'a pas beaucoup
envie de parler et surtout que moi aussi
j'étais dans la position adéquat de
demander des questions superficiel comme
on me demande à moi de chasse est en
faisant une interview ce que vous
travaillez pour la peau la rai à
l'époque un viol oui j'ai des petits
reportages avez fait quoi comme ce
couple
on me jette avait plein de gens mais je
travaillais trop grand programme de
comédiens italiens qui s'appelle rennes
soit formé mais un terrier été très con
du fbi c'était très drôle amusant
et mais je trouve même un mondial par
exemple john atta mills était intervenu
très sérieux moi j'étais terrifiée lui
je vous avais dit s'appeler rossellini
femmes comment la vivez vous dirait un
peu probablement détruit finale moi je
crois que ça et ça n'est pas que ça
n'aide pas d'être finie mais c'est pas
suffisant pour vous faire des carrières
même mais ça aide au début ça eh oui les
gens semblent alors c'est en faisant une
interview pour la rai donc vous avez
rencontré notre premier mari c'était
alors une exposition qui a lieu en ce
moment au palais de tokyo oui vous donc
c'est isabella rossellini photographier
par les plus grands photographes du mans
il ya quoi il a le coeur sur vous il
ya ce que vous levant il ya peter grimes
vega par e mail il ya dominique
issermann ivan merveilleux
une petite merveille avec le bien de
tous ces photographes vous préférez
travailler
vous savez je vous laisserai ce que
c'est très intéressant que ces deux
cocottes au travail avec les
photographes se voir le résultat passe
nos voix d'une manière très différente
de l'autre et j'ai mis tout le groupe
qui est exposé au palais de tokyo
vraiment
cessé mes favoris vous de dire avec avec
donkey qui est pas inclus dans l'air
parce que
là bas mais non mais parce que je crois
que
c'est un autre niveau
l'upc exposition seulement réagi et
je les aime tous mais c'était
intéressant de voir la différence parce
que finalement on ne photographie tout
comme tout comme une belle femme parce
que ces photos que je fais c'est
probable c'est que ce soit pour la mode
la beauté dans sept jours ils cherchent
toujours de trouver nantes qui est beau
parent non le dramatique et mais c'est
différent sur devoir comme comme les
gens interprètent ce que c'est la beauté
est ce que c'est l'élégance à succès
puisqu'une à travers les photos plutôt
oui c'est ma façon en vélo sur fanatic
rstri nestor almendros
le dit que les visages pour lui c'est
comme les paysages et qu' ils adorent
les visages des femmes ou des hommes à
photographier parce que c'est comme les
paysages c'est eux qui interprète qui
voit qui est là et je crois que c'est ça
mon visage finalement est un espèce de
lézard ou 2,66 et comme désormais mais
mon chaque modèle c'est vraiment pour
moi c'est intéressant de voir lors il ay
de chaque
section alors vous vous êtes devenus top
model à l'époque enfin un âge où les
gens oui j'étais très et j'avais lu que
les gens sont en général
madame cawi du temps oui moi j'étais
vous je crois que je me faisais pas vrai
oui mais j'ai beaucoup de chance parce
que quand j'ai arrêté de faire les
interviews nos comptes arrêtez de nous
avons arrêté de faire ce programme qui
s'appelle attrait dominique à qui était
plutôt d'accord mais dix étaient les
amusant moi j'ai pensé de faire de la
journée mystérieusement c'était très
difficile parce que peut-être
j'entendais tout le temps mes parents
qui est parti à la maison visée c'est
juste un super réveillon
et moi j'avais toujours de la peine
surtout comment nous on est constamment
de faire évidemment les gens du cinéma
petits conseils avec mon chéri
j'arrivais les interviews et moi je me
sentais mal crâne comptabilité et un
jour bruce weber m'a demandé de faire
une photo et deux semaines plus tard
mais qui ne m'a appelé pour
qu'américains trois semaines plus tard
j'étais dans ce lieu avait donc tout
s'est passé très vite l'inquiétude vous
étiez fait pour ça je suis c'était
fantastique parce que je déjà merci
aussi bienvenus c'est vrai que dans tous
les métiers pour faut travailler très
durement pour y réussir mais c'est
merveilleux quand vous accepte mais
quand vous avez travaillé dur oui après
les durs mais je me suis tellement se
dit accepter mais que faites-vous il
doit dire cette heure alors que vous
êtes vous êtes sous contrat avec lancôme
oui de plusieurs années on a renouvelé
tous les deux à quatre fois ça fait huit
ans alors nous on arrive des fois non
non ça fait six ans à renouveler pour
atteindre 145 pays oui on le fait plat
plat pays dans toulouse
alors quels sont les quelles sont les
contraintes est ce que par exemple quand
on vous dit que
vous êtes très joli sur un ton
formidable où je vais y répondre que
c'est grâce à l' encore
baisser aussi grâce à la cour parce que
c'est vrai que 120 kg sommes voulait pas
d'une fière de vous n'êtes vous pas de
vrais bons caf que je travaille je suis
pas aussi qu'en fait vous faites des
photos quand vous êtes en vacances avec
votre mari est ce qu'il veut quand il
veut croire est ce que votre mari vous
prend en photo pour cette tournée oui on
se prend au bon sang froid dont moi je
suis plus désolé mais on se prend en
photo parce que c'est toujours de sa
bande d'amis en effet
jamais non oui en effet quand je vois
les albums de famille et je vois les
photos de ballons revers si je me dis
oui c'est le photographe et c'est le
maquillage lancôme qui met vos mains
c'est contraignant à part ça je veux
dire de
ces passionnants au début quand je
travaillais comme finances comme modèle
au travail partout cet été pas sûr à en
venir à paris pour les collections en
italie et quand autres conçus pour la
première année j'étais un peu à un
malaise parce que là bas et c'est
beaucoup plus pisser versé beaucoup plus
mais après six ans j'ai des coups ça
devient très dur en anglais andy
challenging secret
c'est le travail et 140 pays que tout le
monde vous aime en fait les produits
partout cdu c'est le même modèle jeu
travers le monde est de réussir à tout
ça dort ici pendant plusieurs années
c'est une très grande ce disque gens et
je suis beaucoup le travail aussi avez
vous avez vu le figaro madame cette
semaine oui j'étais en couverture et
puis on ouvrait la page vous êtes
horizons alors oui je troisième bateau
de partir à gauche 82 on fait des films
c'est quel bilan vous tiré de votre
carrière cinématographique les magazines
théorique et une carrière chaotique
chaotique oui pour les précédents je
confesse parce que au début quand
j'étais teenagers je me disais non je
vais faire quelque chose de complètement
différent tu vas me dis qu'en dise on se
trouve que c'est presque naturel de
faire la même chose que le parent enfant
parce que on les connaît d'une certaine
manière et comme les enfants des avocats
pour les avocats des enfants des
médecins essaient de faire autre chose
vraiment vous trouverez la même chose
oui la même chose en fait c'est arrivé
ça mais je les fais toujours au début
avec un tout petit peu de complexes et
d'être modèle m'a beaucoup aidé parce
que l'être réussi dans une autre milieu
m'a donné assez de confiance en moi pour
tenter de faire l'actrice parce que
c'est difficile quand on est dans une
sphère qui sont reconnus parce qu'on a
peur que on est jugé par rapport à mai
le fait que j'étais je vais bien réussi
comme modèle ça m'a donné confiance
bon si je n'allais pas en lui indiquant
comme quand j'avais fait blue velvet par
exemple parce que le rôle était quand
même assez vous savez où il jouera qu'il
était inquiet mais je dois dire que l'on
mon agent que j'avais à l'époque -
l'agent de cinéma était complètement
folle il voulait pas et c'est lui qui
m'a laissé cedro là aussi on est plus à
travailler ensemble la prom était
toujours très
fortement discret elle était toujours
solide demande dix ans on voit ci aura
des problèmes ça nous pose des problèmes
on va prendre des résolutions si ça nous
pose pas un problème qui reste notre
modèle et ça c'est très courageux bien
puis le film s'est bien passé il a eu du
succès et le milan comme là il est très
fort très bonne idée merci soyez pas la
fille des griffes dehors
votre premier mari dont elle s'était
scorsese fait j'étais mariée avec le
deuxième red man the lui non oui j'ai
une petite fille de 4 ans et demi
maintenant je passe vous êtes mariés
mais enfin vous êtes vous pensez que
c'est parce c'est parce que vous avez
fait ce film ensemble parce qu'il vous a
vus il a découvert en vous des choses
que certaines choses ça vous a rapproché
est ce que comment ça s'est passé non en
six rencontres on s'est rencontrés puis
van der rohe cuir et cédric au dossier
avant le long non ces conducteurs d'un
film que c'est un film que c'est à vigo
et
ben non je crois que
non c'est pas vraiment lié au film bcbe
contre travers avec les gens devient
très intimes sont plus que bien sûr nous
y sommes ça il a dû quand ils vont
découvrir chez vous des choses que oui
peut-être les autres garçons savent pas
selon nous ça mais les autres aussi mais
non c'est pas ça c'est que sa quête
d'intimité et
et puis des fois l'amour ouais mais
c'était pas que spécialement et des
vides moi je trouve un homme
exceptionnel et intelligent et à chaque
fois c'est ça que je suis tombée
amoureuse au lit c'est pas parce qu'il a
découvert des choses en noir comme
surtout que je sens que quand on fait
les films qu teamsite des fois découvrir
des choses de soi même et on est presque
si on les connaît pas du tout en les
nuits on ne peut pas on peut pas les
interpréter et on interprète déjà
quelque chose qui est déjà assez mûr
dont nous sommes si avec quelque chose
que j'avais découvert j'avais déjà
découvrir mois
quand vous étiez comme vous étiez petit
vous vous trouviez joli nom moi j'ai
quand j'étais petit j'étais très grasse
oui oui et donc je me trouvais pas joli
du tout j'étais petit
j'ai oublié changer quoi on vous quand
j'étais petit
moi je voulais faire son
châtiment rallye kadhafi d'y répondre
mais changer
sa carrière sans marquer maintenant
c'est précis et maintenant c'est vous
c'est moi j'ai changé d'avis
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu